start subject wonderful power
now the servant was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god
had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god
said
he shall not eat of every tree of the
garden
and a woman said unto the serpent we may
eat of the fruit of the trees of the
garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden god hath said
you shall not leave it
neither shall he touch it lest he die
and the serpent said unto the woman
ye shall not surely die
for god doesn't know
that in the day you eat thereof then
your eyes shall be opened and ye shall
be as gods
knowing good and evil
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food
and that it was pleasant to the eyes and
a tree to be desired to make one wise
she took of the fruit thereof ended it
and gave also unto her husband with her
and he leaked
and the eyes and then both were opened
and they knew that they were naked
and they saw fig leaves and made
themselves
aprons god is good
all the time and all the time
good evening everyone
how was your day
it was all right
you're not too sure well whatever kind
of day you had or i had we're grateful
to god that we can be here in his house
can you say amen
there are parts of the world where you
cannot assemble this way to worship the
god of heaven and earth you just cannot
do it and so we thank god for the
privilege of freedom of worship that is
still a privilege in this blessed
country
i'm glad to see you i always am
and i pray that the lord will
so possess me
you know there are two ways to be
possessed by the devil or by god
i want to be holy spirit possessed are
you following me not demon possessed
holy you say demon possessed people have
no control
holy spirit possessed people have given
up control
are you not with me
a demon-possessed person has no control
a holy spirit possessed person has given
up control to the holy spirit amen so
whatever you say that's what i do and so
i want to be holy spirit possessed
he is the spirit of truth
and i want him to speak through me that
what i say may bless your lives because
your father in heaven loves you very
much he loves you very personally he
really does he loves you intimately and
he sent christ to die
for you
god bless the person next to you but he
sent christ to die for you this is very
clear from the parable of the lost sheep
what matter of you having a hundred
sheep if he lose one
does not leave the 1909 in the
wilderness and go after that which is
lost until he find it the shepherd goes
looking for the lost sheep he does not
bring the 9009 with him
he goes looking for the sheep it is just
the sheep and the shepherd salvation as
i have told you before is a personal
matter
it is not a tribal matter it is not a
matter of family tradition it is an
individual matter and very often it
requires individuals to make decisions
that go contrary to the rest of the
family
and i take courage to do that but jesus
christ can understand you if you are in
that position because the bible tells us
in john chapter 7 verse 5 neither did
his brethren believe in him there was a
time in the life of christ when the
family as astonishing as it may sound
did not believe in him
and so if you're in that predicament
jesus understands
when the angel gabriel told zacharias
to call his son john
when the baby was born
in luke 159 all the neighbors all the
friends on the eighth day i should say
they came to set to uh circumcise him
and they decided to call him zacharias
after the name of his father elizabeth
said no his name is john
the family said to her there is no one
in this family that has that is called
by that name this is not a family
tradition that's the argument they use
this is not a triangle tradition this is
not a cultural tradition she said her
point was god said john
and regardless of what the family
tradition may be god said john
and we need courage to stand against
family
friends
society
countries governments whenever we find
ourselves standing on thus
saith the lord
what other people think
is not important we ought to obey god
finish the verse for me
rather than
i didn't mean to preach twice but that
was on my my mind i suppose is there
anyone with us tonight
for the first time you are not a seventh
adventist it makes your head
ah oh
and i started and left good evening
how are you
what's your name
lynette
what's your last name
hollywood
how are you sister lynette
nice to see you
thank you very much for coming god bless
you for coming and god bless whoever
invited you
can you tell us who that person is
ah
pastor you're busy man god bless you
okay
thank you for god bless you in every
possible way my brother i saw your hand
what's your name
mark jackson mark dixon mark is a good
bible name mark where are you from
where
where is that
god bless everybody that way thank you
mark for coming god bless you
and god provide your needs in such
abundance that you can be a blessing to
somebody else
did i see another hand beside mark
did i where
what's your name
who glory laurie hello laurie where are
you from
that way okay all right well it's nice
to have you glory god bless you bless
you bless you
and may that god's blessing be like a
rain shower in your life that soaks you
to your spiritual skin thank you for
coming
god bless you did i see another happen
ah
yes
are you threatening to raise your hand
or are you raising it all right what's
your name
jennifer how are you jennifer
good to see you where are you from
okay
that's where i'm from chestertown right
here jericho god bless you thank you
very much for coming and for all of you
god bless whoever invited you may the
lord place his hand of mercy upon you
jennifer and keep it on you until he
guides you into his kingdom
did i see your hand
what's your name
donna
hello donna
how are you
where are you from
that way in this way
thanks for coming donna
who invited you
ah yes that's a good man dr david all
right
may the lord bless you and grant you the
desires of your heart whatever they may
be say amen for all our guests
come on say it again
one more time
god is good
and all the time
yes yes i like god i really do
he's a nice person
and i find her fault of god you know
jesus said they hated me without a cause
which means
there is never a legitimate reason to be
angry with god
never now we are angry all the time
because we suffer from temporary
insanity but there is never a legitimate
reason come on
to get angry with god jesus said they
hated me come on without a cause
[Music]
might says of god the lord is righteous
in all his ways how can you be angry
with a god who is always right but we're
finite we're human with us and god
understands
psalm 103 verse 14 for he knoweth our
frame he remembers that we are dust and
thus acts crazy from time to time
for this evening
wonderful power what did i say wonderful
wonderful power before i jump into the
message it's already 7 15 i'll release
you before 8 o'clock please if you have
one of these make sure it's turned off
if you're using it as your bible that's
fine but you don't need sound and the
reason for this request we must preserve
a reverence in the presence of a holy
god are you following me and god will
appreciate that
when god is happy he blesses he blesses
he blesses let's keep god happy by
referencing his holy name tonight
number two while i'm speaking pray for
me and say lord put your words in that
man's mouth i really mean that from time
to time in the privacy of your heart
certainly say father put your words in
that man's mouth
that request is based on jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put
forth his hand and touched my mouth and
the lord said unto me behold i have put
my words in thy mouth and that's what i
want god to do for me tonight it is a
serious responsibility to speak for god
and if you ever have to do that make
sure you're saying thus saith the lord
anything else is an insult to god who is
the god of truth the holy spirit is
called truth the son is called truth god
loves truth
number three think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together saith the lord i've told
you before god is a reasonable god
the devil is not
satan is unreasonable but god is very
reasonable when cain killed he came down
where is your brother when there was a
catastrophe in the garden of guess uh
even he came down adam where are you eve
what did you do
he knows all these things but he invited
talk to me
talk to me says god i'll listen
i love that about god let us pray
our father
we thank you for your love
we thank you for sparing our lives today
for bringing us to this house of worship
and the center and focus of our worship
is you
if we sinned against your father
forgive us
and grant to us a greater degree of
hatred for sin
and an endless love for righteousness
father i humble myself before you
and i ask you in the name of jesus
christ
to possess me completely
every apparatus required to deliver this
message you possess it a god
let me be merely an instrument in your
hand i offer no resistance
tell me what to say
when to say it how to say it
bless those listening i pray grant them
comprehension that the word of god may
do its work in the lives of those
listening in person and those online
they god if everyone listening to me is
has contracted 19 i'm appealing to you
in the name of jesus heal those persons
father 100
because you merciful god not only those
who believe in you i also ask you to
heal the unbelievers because your word
says he maketh his son to rise on the
evil and on the good so father spread
your mercy over the sick
we thank you for the guests who are
honest i ask your father very directly
bless them their god
let them know they have been blessed by
the god of heaven on earth now dear god
use me i pray please in jesus name
amen
genesis chapter 1 let's read verse 26
our subject wonderful power
genesis sister mary nice to see you
i have missed you
nice to see you
all right what book did i say genesis
chapter one genesis chapter one we read
verse 26 is a very familiar verse you
know it very well
when you found it say amen amen
and god said let us make man how you
know in our image after our likeness
stop
and god said
let us make man
in
our image
[Music]
in order yes in order to understand what
that means we need to understand what is
the image of god
in which mankind was made i refer of
course to adam and also to eve
let us go to deuteronomy chapter 32.
we'll read the last part of verse 4 of
deuteronomy 32.
amen all right good brother you're quick
tonight okay
the rest of you have you caught with my
good brother you're deuteronomy 32 verse
4 the last part of that verse the bible
refers to god as a god of truth and
without law
in liberty finish the verse
just and
right is he he is a god without iniquity
what kind of god is he
he's perfect give me another word
right he's righteous give me another
word listen he a god of truth and
without iniquity what kind of god is he
perfect sin lessons are what i wanted
but all the other four to five but i
want to say less a god of truth and
without iniquity
that's gone
let's go to john
chapter 14.
let's read verse 30 of john 14.
john is a beautiful book really sometime
beautiful book beautiful
you have john 14
verse 30
read with me hereafter i will not walk
talk with you for the prince of this
world cometh finish the verse and have
nothing in me
what does he mean by he has nothing in
me what is this satan could not find in
christ
what was it satan could not find in
sin
now go to john 10 30.
john chapter 10
verse 30 on subject wonderful power
it's twenty after seven i'll release you
before eight or eight most likely before
eight
not eight a.m tomorrow morning
that's a private joke for those of you
who look confused all right john chapter
10 let's read verse 33 verse well not
very short but what does that say
i
and my father
are one
are the same thing in character not one
person
in character in mind in this position
i and my father
are one
now
which means if the father is sinless how
can we describe the son is it less
let's go to first john chapter three
our subject wonderful power
we need to understand
what is meant by let us make man in our
image
first john chapter three we read four
five
is towards the back of the bible find
revelation revelation jude third john ii
john first john
do you have that now
read with me
whosoever
committed sin
transgresseth also the law come on for
sin
is the transgression of the lord now
read verse 5 nice and clear and
you know that he was
manifested to the wall take away our sin
and in him come on is no sin
now we're talking about a sinless god
go to jeremiah chapter two
jeremiah chapter two
the weaving prophet
no matter how he preached nobody
listened
and they paid a terrible price
it's a dangerous thing not to listen to
thus saith the lord
amen jeremiah 2 verse 5 are you there
amen read with me what
thus says yes what what illegally have
your father's
thumb in me
gotta say what have i done wrong
can your fathers point to anything that
i have ever done wrong what in liberty
have your fathers found in me
what michael chapter six
micro six let's read verse three i think
it is
you have that
amen really what does that say
oh my people come on
what have i
undoubtedly and women have i
with me read carefully now
testify
take me to court
sue me says god
see if you win that case
i have never
ever done you anything wrong we're
establishing the fact that god is
sinless and perfect now we go back to
genesis 1 26 there's no need to go you
know what does it say and god said let
us make man how
stop let's make man how
let us make man how to stay less
just the way we are
now
we're not saying enter the world we know
that
let's go to genesis 5 let's read verse
3.
time's flying quickly tonight it's
already 7 25.
i'll try to slow it down maybe joshua
were here he could do that
do you have where did i send you
genesis 5 verse 3 let me pray again
father as i continue to speak to those
whom you love in person and online tell
me exactly what to say direct me control
me god in jesus name i pray amen
and i will live how long a hundred and
thirty years and began
how he don't like it it is all like this
come on after
his image now
so we have a different image on the
earth
we have the one in verse 26 of genesis 1
and god said let us make man how in our
image now we have a second image
the first image is based on what
god on god's
character synthesis the second one is
based on adam's sinful character by the
way
the sinful character did not begin with
adam
that's why jesus can say in john 8 44 ye
are of your father
the devil
and the lust of your father the sinful
nature the rebellious mindset against
god began with satan when he rebelled
against god long before adam was made
that's why he was cast out in revelation
12 9.
let me say it again the carnal sinful
rebellious nature which we inherited
from adam did not originate with adam it
originated with satan so christ can
correctly say ye are of your father the
devil
hey first john chapter 3 verse 12 let's
go there and strengthen that point first
john chapter 3 we read 11 and 12 our
subject wonderful power
you have that first john 3 11 and 12.
read with me so this is the message that
he heard from the beginning that what
we should love one another listen to
kirsten
not as cain who was
his own works were righteous and his
brothers his owners were evil and his
brother's righteous
saint
cain is described as a child of the
wicked one and that's not a reference to
adam that's a reference to
satan
go to john 17.
christ has prayed and father and the
disciples are standing by listening to
him pray
let's read verse 12
of john 17.
i've told before tell me slow down when
i go too quickly
i tend to do that when i'm excited
you have john 17 12
read with me
while i was with them in the world i
kept them in thy name those that thou
gave to me i have kept and none of those
loss finished the verse but the son of
perdition that the scripture might be
fulfilled the son of perdition is a
title also given to the antichrist who's
representative of satan
jesus called judas the son of perdition
a son of the devil
which is a title for the antichrist in
second thessalonians chapter 2 verse 3
also called the man of sin
we have
christ
satan
now
because of sin something had to be done
to
bring us back to the way it was before
adam sinned
let me say differently
the purpose of the gospel
the purpose of the sacrifice of christ
is not to improve people it is to
transform them
amen amen
is to restore even the image ever
possessed before he sinned let me say
that again the purpose of the gospel is
to restore by transforming sinners back
into the original mold which was a
sinless moment
as though jesus christ came
and lived the life
adam should have lived
he lived a life the chosen people should
have lived
this is the life that god requires and
jesus christ lived that life and he
offers that life to us and that love
is a righteous life amen
let's take a look at righteousness
because righteousness is
power
as verily as sin
is power
you see sin
is power to disobey
i didn't say sin is freedom to disobey
there is no freedom in sin sin is power
to disobey righteousness
yes
righteousness is power to obey
you look at me as if you say give me a
bible verse
go to deuteronomy chapter 6
7 30 on the dot
deuteronomy 6 very verse 25
i said righteousness is power to obey
have verily a sin is power to disobey
but with sin there's no freedom with
righteousness there's freedom because a
sinner cannot leave the devil unless
someone comes against him amen
let me say it slowly a sinner cannot
leave christ unless someone comes and
gets him name that person jesus christ
through the spirit someone serving god
can leave any time he wants
[Music]
without anyone coming together
that's freedom
amen what book did i say
wrong what chapter chapter 6 one verse
read carefully read microscopically and
this shall be our
righteousness if we observe to do what
all these commandments
righteousness is conformity to the law
of god
this shall be unrighteousness
me put it differently
the life god required of adam before he
sinned
was to be a righteous life
the life required of us
after adam's sin is still to be a
righteous life
now it has to be done through christ
before i am saying there was no need for
him to live a righteous life through
christ there was no need for that
after sin humanity became helpless and
needed a savior to assist them in living
a righteous life the life of christ
is the life required of adam before he
sinned required after he said and
required of us today but because we're
sinners by birth but i say that i mean
because we're born needing a savior we
need an intercessor a mediator someone
through whom we can live that righteous
life i said earlier sin
is the power to disobey
now sin is a power
righteousness is a power let me say
differently sin is a life
it's a twisted life
righteousness is a straight life
amen
how are we saved
all right let's go to first peter
chapter one
first video one we read 18 and 19 our
subject wonderful power
first peter 1 18 and 19.
you have that first peter
chapter 1
and 19
all right
for as much as you know that you were
not redeemed with corruptable things as
silver and gold from your vain
conversation received by tradition from
your fathers but with the precious blood
of christ as a lamb without blemish and
without spot we're redeemed
by the precious blood of christ
i'm introducing the word blood
we frequently hear christ shed his blood
what does that mean let's go to
revelation chapter one
let's read verse five
revelation verse one chapter one sorry
reading verse five our subject wonderful
power
and from jesus christ who is the
faithful witness and the first begotten
of the dead and the prince of the kings
of the earth with me now unto him that
from our sins in his own blood we know
from hebrews 9 22 without shedding of
blood there's no one no religion there's
no forgiveness without blood but what
are you to understand by blood because i
said sin is a twisted life righteousness
is a straight life
go to genesis 9
this is the chapter in which iran not
abraham sorry noah they are out of the
ark in chapter eight god gives them
instructions in chapter nine because
life on earth is beginning all over
again and if you read genesis 9 verse 1
it sounds very similar to what god told
aaron before there was a flood before
they were saved
you have genesis nine
read first one with me and god did one
blessed lord his sons and said unto them
what be fruitful and multiply and
replenish the earth that's what god told
adam
so noah is a kind of adam starting all
over again
but this time they still have the carnal
nature are you following me now let's go
to verse 4 of genesis 9 as god gives
directions regarding diet he gave
directions regarding diet to adam
genesis 1 29 30 he gives directions
regarding diet to noah as life is about
to begin again what is verse 4 of
genesis 9 say but
flesh with the
life thereof which is the blood thereof
shall he not eat now
life with the
flesh with the
life thereof which is the blood thereof
you see the blood
is a symbol
of the life
all the blood
is a carrier of the life
how do nutrients get to your cells
the blood carries the nutrient are you
following me
the blood
carries the nutrient it is a carrier
when where's dash across the shore it is
not the water causing the damage really
is the energy moving through the water
you see the water you can't see the
energy the blood is a carrier of the
light and so it is frequently used as a
symbol of life now let's go to luke 22
let's read from verse 41. luke 22
reading from verse 41 our subject
wonderful power
let's take a look at
blood we need to understand what the
bible says
you have luke 22 verse 41
this is christ and the god of gethsemane
the bible says and he was withdrawn from
them about the stones cast and kneeled
down and prayed saying father if thou be
willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but thy be done
and they appeared what
and angeled him from heaven
strengthening him the next verse says
and being in an agony he prayed the more
earnestly finished that verse for me now
and his sweat was as it were what great
drops of blood falling down
jesus bled from his skin
in gethsemane
he shed blood
in the assemblies to be carefully
in gethsemane
was that the payment for sin
if christ had changed his mind and gone
back to heaven from the
would he have paid the price for sin no
but he shared blood yes yes but he gave
him his life
no
let me tell you something else about
blood
go to john 10.
we have to understand blood symbolizes
life
because you can bleed and not die
and you can die and not bleed are you
following me
i said that i'm confusing you all right
let's go to john 10 you read for verse
16.
what happened with jesus shed his blood
john 10 16 and other sheep i have which
are not this fold them also i must bring
and they shall hear my voice and they
shall be one fold and one shepherd 17
therefore death my father loved me
because i laid down my
life
not laying down my blood
i lay down
my life that i lay
dig again read eating carefully no man
takes it from me but i lay down on
myself
i have power to lay down i have power to
take it up again this commandment have i
received my father jesus said therefore
that my father loved me because i laid
down my life
the blood symbolizes
the life
we are saved
by the life
of jesus
he gave up
his life
you read luke 23 46 and jesus where he
cried with a loud voice
said that his father father into thy
hand i commend my spirit and having this
spoken he gave up the ghost he gave up
the ghost he gave up his life
let me illustrate it this way
if you and i are in a car traveling on
some highway
and we're here by a truck
and uh
i die did i die for you
no but if i see you in the middle of the
street and the truck is coming and i run
out to get you and i get hit did i die
for you yes
christ died for us so he gave him his
life he wasn't just killed for us he
died for us he gave up the life for us
are you with me he gave it up
that's why he tells us in john 10 17 or
88 no man takes it from me
he gave up his life
but that life
is righteousness
the life of christ
is a righteous life
and as we read in uh
romans 5 10 if when we were enemies we
will reconcile to god by the death of
his son much more being reconciled we
shall be saved by
his life
it is the life of god
the life of christ that saves her but
the blood is a symbol as a carrier of
that life symbolically jesus gave his
life
his life
is a righteous life
that's why jeremiah 6 23
23 6 tells us
his name is the lord our righteousness
his very name is righteousness he is
righteousness his life righteousness is
a life
as verily as sin is a life
which has expressions
if someone
has never given their life to christ
and the person is in a coma
is a person still a sinner yes or no
yes
does the person need jesus yes is the
person committing active acts of sin no
it's a sinner yes
the life is a sin for life even though
the person is in a coma the life is a
sinful life and that person still needs
a savior and the saving work of god is
to exchange his life
for ours
and so he gives us
his righteous life
and he takes on him
our sin
what does that mean
it's a terrible exchange when i say
terrible it's painful for god
go to hebrews 1
hebrews 1
wonderful power
that power is the power to do right and
that power is righteousness hebrews 1
let's read verse
of hebrews 1
17 8
this is god the father speaking
what did he say
thou has loved righteousness and
hated iniquity
god hates one thing
tell me
sin
and the very thing he hates
on jesus christ had to take
not just on him
he took it in him first peter 1 24
who his own self
224 who his own self bear our sins in
his own body on the cross jesus took on
to him and in him the thing he hates the
most he took it into him why
that he might give us
his life
that life is the power to do what is
right
that life is a righteous life and so
paul says i can do how many things all
things are for christ we're straight
with me and the strength of christ is
the very life of christ and the saint
paul says i am crucified with christ
nevertheless i live yet not i but christ
liveth in me the righteous life of
christ is expressed in me
amen
as rarely as the blood carries the life
so are we to be carriers of the life of
christ righteousness is the very life of
christ go to romans chapter 6
romans 6
i'd like to deal with this verse that
wouldn't even serve any of my sermons
very direct very powerful rule 6 let me
pray as you look for it father as i
continue the downslope of this message
be with me still i pray in jesus name
amen wonderful power the power of the
life of christ the power of
righteousness as opposed to the power of
sin
knowing not
that
you yield yourself that's romans 6 16
knowing not that who yield yourselves
servants to obey his servancy are to
whom you obey whether of
sin unto
now let's pause there take a deep breath
i said righteousness is life
look at that verse again we have two
pairs of opposites
what are they
listen to the verse look at it while i
say
no are you not in others do you not know
that to whom yield yourselves servants
to obey his certainty are to whom you
obey in other words life is a matter of
obeying
the question is whom shall i obey you
either obey god or you obey the devil
you have no choice other than that you
can choose whom but you can choose not
to obey
the bible is clear every living being
obeys not a god either god or satan
knowing not that to whom yield
yourselves service to obey his servants
you are to whom you obey whether of
sin
what does that lead to
death or of
now look at those two pairs of opposites
near the first pair
same hand
say it again
one more time
what's the other pair
now on the chalkboard of your mind
put sin
death
obedience
righteousness or life okay
are you with me sin
death
obedience
life
what's the opposite of sin
obedience ah god bless you my sister i
like you
yes the opposite of sin lift ease of
sin unto death obedience unto one right
righteousness now the order of sin is
obedience what's the opposite of death
based on those titles
ah you're looking at me laughing at me
now let's try again
you have to see this
word of sin unto death
obedience unto righteousness the
opposite of sin in that verse is
obedience the opposite of death is
righteousness because righteousness is
life
doing right
is a life
and the power to do right is doing right
itself
you didn't hear what i said
someone said well i can't keep the
sabbath i said no you can
the power to keep the sabbath is in
keeping the south
don't wait for power and then go keep it
it doesn't work like that stop keeping
it and you'll find the power is working
the power of obedience lies in obedience
whether sin to death
are of obedience
unto righteousness which is life
also the old testament you can find
verses that talk about obedience
is life
what is romney eight
deuteronomy eight let's read from verse
one
our subject wonderful power the power of
righteousness which is the life of
christ christ's life is righteousness
his kingdom is based on that
do you remember it from verse one
really what does that say
all commandments come on which
outcome that you made
go to romans 5.
read verse 19.
[Music]
by the obedience of one shall maybe be
righteous but
go to verse 18 reverse it it says the
same thing using different words
what does that first say for satan
wherefore
we have righteousness and offense in
verse 18.
we have obedience and disobedience in
verse 19 they are saying
the same thing
in verse 18 we have offense
which is sin the opposite righteousness
here first mighty we have
disobedience and obedience so the
offense in 18 is disobedience in
nineteen the
righteousness in that verse 18 is the
obedience in 19.
righteousness
is the life of christ
it is the power
to obey as verily as sin is the power to
disobey
the difference is
we have to choose righteousness
but we're born hating god
romans 8 4 7 because the carnal mind is
empty against god that's how we're born
for it is not subject to the law of god
it is not the carnal mind cannot obey
god to god's satisfaction
in the eyes of god the carnal nature
cannot obey
you know people in prison comply they
don't obey
are you with me
they comply because they don't want one
punishment
a converted person obeys as an
expression of love
people in penitentiaries comply
a converted person or peace
as an expression
of love
knowing not
that the whom yield yourselves servants
to obey his servancy are to whom you
obey whether sin
unto death
or of obedience and righteousness
righteousness is life
now go back to hebrews 1 let me close it
off hebrews 1
let's read from verse 8.
this is god the father speaking to his
son jesus christ hebrews 1 reading from
verse 8.
we're concluding wonderful power that
power is the power to obey god that
power is the righteous life of christ
which gives us a gift you can't earn it
do you have hebrews one verse eight
thy throne oh god this is the father
speaking is forever and ever a sector of
righteousness is the center of thy
kingdom now what does a sector symbolize
what what did i hear
a rulership give another word
start with a p then an o then a w
the power of christ's kingdom is
righteousness
amen
of righteousness is the sector of thy
kingdom righteousness is the power that
drives the kingdom of god
and so we read in psalm 13 verse 20
speaking of the angels
bless the lord he is angels
that do his will hearkening obey his
commandments heartening unto the voice
of his word the angels obey god
they keep his commandments
[Music]
and that life is the life of christ he
lives it in us
and through us
you cannot live that life separated from
christ you can live a decent life not a
righteous life
romans 8 4 1 there's therefore now no
condemnation to them which are in christ
jesus who walk not after the flesh but
after the spirit for the law of the
spirit of life in christ jesus has made
me free from the law of sin and death
where is the law of his obedience are
you following me you either obey the law
of life or the law of sin
for what the law could not do in that it
was weak through the flesh god sending
his own son in the likeness of sinful
flesh and forsaken condemned sin in the
flesh read verse 440.
that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilled where in us who walked not
after the flesh but after the spirit
christ came that that righteous life
might be expressed in us christ came
that through the outpouring of his life
you and i may be able to go back through
christ
to the life god required of adam
before he sinned this may boggle the
mind but god does not change his
standards listen to me
god requires of us today
the life he required of adam before
adam sinned and that life was a
righteous life and so the bible says in
romans 5 verse 12 no need to go there
wherefore as my one man sin entered into
the world name that one man jesus christ
[Music]
and christ came that the righteousness
of the law
might be fulfilled
in us
and it's a gift
the love you see christ lived the life
now he offers that life as a gift
here's the life
here's my hard drive
put it in you
start living my life
it's a gift the carnal nature is an
inheritance
[Music]
the life of christ
is a gift
but we've got to believe in him with how
much of our hearts
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart with all thy soul with all
thy mind
if you love god with 99 of your soul to
whom have you given the one percent
and that's all the enemy needs to
destroy your
life me say this quickly
to save us god needs one hundred percent
of the life
to destroy us the devil only needs a
little peace
i didn't say that clearly you look
beautifully confused let me say it again
to save us
god needs to tell me
of the life given to me to destroy us
the devil he needs a little peace
ask god
to grant you that gift of the righteous
life of christ
that is the power to conquer sin the
righteous life of christ
now when you ask god for that it is
christ himself in a mysterious way i
cannot explain and will not try to
explain he lives it up from the inside
out through the presence of his holy
spirit
and so tonight
i ask god
father
i surrender myself to you
please they god
put that life of christ
within me
that i may have the power
to obey
not so much from the mind but from the
heart
how many will say with me genuinely
father give me that life of christ can i
see your hand
do you mean that yes or no
stand up with me
let me tell you with respect
jesus said
as it was in the days of noah
so shall it be also in the days of the
coming of the son of man
what were they doing in the days of noah
they drank they married wives they were
given in marriage that's what decent
people do
lost
christ also said likewise also as it was
in the days of lord
they dried they bought they saw they
planted
one of those things what decent people
do
there were lost
it is not a decent life that qualifies
you or me for kingdom it is the life of
christ in us
i told you a couple nights ago when in
the old testament where they brought a
lamb to be sacrificed the priest
examined the lamb
not the decent life of the person the
lamb
we need christ
we have to be in him so when the father
looks he sees the life of christ as our
life jesus expresses this by saying i am
the tree you are branch
whatever flows through me will bring to
you is the light my life is the life
that sustains you the life of a
righteous god
has bowed eyes closed dear god
take what i said in my clumsy way
simplify through the work of the spirit
and apply to those who heard father in
this building and online
it is an important message
righteousness is a powerful life
it is the power to live a life that
pleases you
as verily a sin is the power to rebel
against you
that sinful life will inherit the
righteous life we must receive as a gift
when we request it
i pray father that everyone who heard
this message will develop a desire a
thirst for the righteous life of christ
which is the power to obey
as we leave let us reflect on what we've
heard dear god bless everyone who
listened bring us back tomorrow to this
place and online wherever your people
are to listen to your word again i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen you may be seated
[Music]
you